voici presque deux mois que le cabinet
de kinésithérapie est fermé alors pour
sa réouverture le 4 mai prochain l'heure
est au grand nettoyage
les kinés font partie de ces professions
indépendantes qui ont vu avec le co
vident leurs activités et leurs revenus
s'écroulent et c'est particulier parce
qu'on a eu quand même des consignes un
peu contradictoire du début à la fin où
on nous a demandés fortement conseillé
de fermer les cabinets et arrêter notre
activité est en même temps prendre par
exemple des patients en situation de
soins urgents ensuite on n'avait pas de
matériel au début donc c'était très
difficile d'assurer aussi une continuité
des soins avec justement ces patients
dits fragiles une période caractérisée
par une perte sèche en un mois et demi
cassis renard n'a par exemple réalisé
que 500 euros de chiffre d'affaires
aucune mesure des doux de chômage
partiel n'est appliquée pour cette
profession d'où l'impatience de rouvrir
mais il y aura beaucoup de changements
on n'a plus le droit d'avoir plus de
deux personnes en salles d'attentes
avec les restrictions de un mètre
cinquante de distance sauf peut-être les
mineurs accompagnés de leurs parents
mais voilà pareil mâché par exemple
spécialisé en maxillo-faciale et donc du
coup on ne va pas porter la billière on
va devoir porter des manches longues on
va vraiment devoir s'équiper pour se
protéger nous et pour protéger les
patients nos familles le numéro tu
appelles est comme ça on aura remarqué
leur rendez vous d'accord on fait comme
ça qui pourra avoir des risques au
cabinet parce que maintenant six mois
l'apport du match
je fais je ne trouve fournir des masques
pour les clients qui n'en n'ont pas
c'est l'un des engagements du cabinet il
sera également impossible de prendre
rendez vous sur place pour respecter les
distances de sécurité